what happened at the wuhan lab in 2019
and our own government's support of
controversial research there
may be the tipping point for china
and its american collaborators of which
there are many
now fox news confirmed this week that
the biden administration quashed an
ongoing investigation into the viruses
origins earlier this year now it had
been initiated by the trump state
department mike pompeo but
sources cnn uh telling cnn that the
evidence for undertaking it
supposedly wasn't solid enough and
relied on
cherry-picked facts now if that were
true
then why didn't the biden administration
say as much at the time
and then launch its own investigation
or or as a virus that killed more than a
half a million americans and cost
trillions of dollars
suddenly not worth investigating not a
big enough deal
or is biden's team afraid of what a real
investigation and an unbiased review of
intel would actually reveal
namely that china was culpable and that
as trump said last spring
the virus escape from the wuhan
institute of virology
but instead while democrats like biden
let the wet market lie
percolate china denied any role
deflected blame
and of course watched the political
fallout hit president trump
the cold truth is this the democrats
helped the ccp
by calling legitimate questions about
kovit's origins conspiracies
all done to hurt trump and they will
never live that down because it makes
them
egregious china enablers
yet none of this none of this would have
been possible
without their co-conspirators in the
press
because while the ccp was busy
destroying documents
and eliminating witnesses cnn
msnbc the new york times etc
they all look the other way and then
they helped biden pelosi and schumer
smear president trump and the rest of us
who were pushing for answers
now the ccp they didn't want trump
calling it the china virus or the wuhan
flu
and then the press jumped in
to promptly help them
saying quote the chinese spawned and
weaponized
the virus this is crazy racist talk
wow okay uh well racist conspiracy
theories are
nothing new for the trump administration
it is racist donald trump so stop using
it he wants to avoid accountability for
his catastrophic response
to this epidemic so he's doing
everything he can to try to push that
responsibility away
and blame it on somebody else and when
it came to the lab leak itself
i think this now retracted article from
politifact says it all
the claim is inaccurate and ridiculous
we rate it
pants on fire of course
this narrative came crashing down after
18 prominent scientists including
one of the researchers who worked with
wuhan virologist
published a letter in the journal
science calling the lab leak theory
viable now this caught the attention of
several
real journalists like science writer
nicholas wade
who then berated everyone who wrote off
the lab league theory in the first place
despite this massive embarrassment
the media are still pointing fingers at
trump
i think the messenger matters i think
during that time when
that theory started to be told it was
buried in an administration and a former
president who often kind of tropped in
kind of racist terms and dog whistles
then president trump and mike pompeo
the secretary of state both suggested
they had seen
evidence that this was formed in a lab
he refused to release the evidence
showing what it was
that made this instantly political
nice try not releasing intelligence
while they were in the middle of an
investigation is instantly political
but halting the investigation into the
pandemic's origins
is somehow not political the fact is
this story
is a ticking time bomb for democrats and
the public health
experts who became viral celebrities
even the washington post felt to raise
the unthinkable now that
the lab leak theory is reality
this also has huge implications for two
other players who are more relevant
right now
president biden and the scientific
community
well i'd add another obvious player
whose credibility is on the line here
the intel community how on earth did
they miss this
or wait maybe they were still too busy
trying to validate that phony dossier
story or covering up for hunter but
or maybe just maybe they had no interest
in pursuing any line of inquiry that
made trump seem
prescient or an investigation that maybe
could stoke anti-china sentiment
in the u.s remember they're more
interested
in fighting white supremacism which they
think is a far greater threat to america
than an evil dictatorship that loosed a
virus on the world and then lied about
it
on top of that it's an open question as
to whether the dems who control
the house intel committee will actually
give us the truth not just because adam
schiff is their leader
but also because his main henchman eric
swalwell
is compromised by a chinese spy let's
not forget that story
and even though the senate did
unanimously finally vote to
declassify all the intel on the kovids
uh kovitz origins they did that today
it is not clear if biden will actually
live up to that will you pledge to
release the report in seoul after 90
days
uh yes that's unless there's something
i'm unaware of
well first of all there's a lot he's
unaware of but it certainly
sounds like this could uh end up being
something that could blow up
uh his soft on china agenda that might
be what comes up so if the lab
leak theory does turn out to be true
biden will actually have to get
tough on china or he's going to have to
suffer the consequences from the voters
at home
biden would be forced to choose between
voters and pleasing his donor base in
big business
big tech and wall street and based on
the
biden approach to china his current
approach to china it's pretty obvious
that he puts multinationals over the
middle class
in my discussion with president xi i
told him we welcome the competition
not looking for conflict we're not
trying to contain china
or or hold it back we have big
disagreements with china on some key
issues absolutely
but climate has to stand alone
republicans on the hill must demand full
and unfettered access to all available
intel
on this issue people like senator tom
cotton must have every chance to meet
directly
with the analysts in the intel community
who looked over this data
and also hear and see for himself and
all of the senators on the committee
what the u.s government actually knows
and as for team fouchy well they
shredded their credibility
long ago by rejecting the actual science
on covid
and pushing insane lockdowns and mask
mandates remember when they were
obsessed with hydroxychloroquine
well fauci was also an unabashed
defender of china
including back in february of 2020
on this show why should we
actually believe them when billions if
not trillions of dollars
is riding on preserving the idea that
all is going to be
okay over the last several weeks the
chinese authorities have really been
very explicit
that they were going to not tolerate any
misinformation going out
so you're satisfied with all of the
transparency coming out of china
today about the trajectory of the
disease and the origin of the disease
in my direct interaction with chinese
scientists
i can believe what they're telling me
now it's clear why fauci was so adamant
that everything from the chinese was
above
board he stands to get crushed if it
turns out that taxpayer dollars
that he helped funnel to the wuhan
institute of virology
in any way played a role in this
pandemic
you gave them money and you said don't
do gain-to-function research
correct and they said we won't correct
and you have no way of knowing whether
they did or not
except you trust them is that right well
we generally always trust the grantee to
do
what they say how do you know they
didn't do the research and
not put it on their website there's no
way of
guaranteeing that let's write him
another check why not let's roll the
dice
well this is exactly why the gop has to
press fouchy the nih
and all other parties involved in this
gain of function money laundering scheme
the more the lies and distractions from
china's useful idiots in the u.s are
exposed
the greater the chance that republicans
have of retaking
congress in 2022 and of retaking the
white house in 2024
right now that seems like the only way
we're actually going to get
real trustworthy answers about the
origins of covid
and we need those answers and that's the
angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else